build it draw it play it vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people this is
bdp building portal fans check out this
homemade robotic glados replica the
control board features a usb interface
so you can send commands telling it to
move as well as speak
anyone can make their own pop-up
monsters these are featured in a film
called waste and they have download
links to the templates as well as
tutorials on how to put together each
different monster
monster caesar studios is the work of
andrew martin a sculptor out of canada
he has some incredible works including a
solarian from mass effect tweedle dumb
from alice in wonderland
and a mounted zombie trophy eric
franklin's embodiment is a neon skeleton
that took 1 000 hours to make the
hundreds of light structures are
hollowed and filled with ionized krypton
they must be perfectly sealed to
preserve the luminosity of the krypton
painting with fire is a technique used
by steven spazak the smokey gesture
drawings are created by exposing the
canvas to fire and then controlling the
imprint of soot his fragmentation
paintings combine smaller works to
create massive portraits meanwhile
michael shapcod's portraits use a paint
over graphite technique he creates the
graphite or carbon drawing then sprays
coating on top so that it doesn't smudge
when he paints over it now the fan art
of dino the atomic circus
[Music]
finally british designer sam hollows
created each of these star wars drawings
using only one continuous line playing
four of drexel university's hubo robots
cover the beatles come together one
thing i can tell you is you got to be
free
come together
right now
over me not to be outdone by this robot
band's cover of maroon 5's moves like
jagger and i'll show you how to move
like dagger i got the moves like jagger
i've got
[Music]
moves like jagger adam ben ezra used
everything from a kazoo to a melodica to
cover this south park theme
[Music]
finally this music video features a
geriatric couple living vicariously
through a first person shooter
submit your own vps as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at facebook.com
vsaucegaming and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]
uh